conclue avec l'espagne et le portugal
mode de scrutin le parti socialiste
laisse le choix au gouvernement claude
estier va s'en expliquer en direct la
mort de marc chagall à mettre de la
lumière et de l'allégorie l'un des plus
grands patrons du ciac non mesdames
messieurs bonsoir décidément on n'a pas
fini d'être surpris par les
rebondissements de la sphère grégory ce
petit garçon assassiné mystérieusement à
l'automne dernier dans les vosges
on croyait l'anc est reparti sur de
nouvelles pistes et voilà qu'arrive un
deuxième meurtre
jean marie villemin le père dit qu'il
vient de tuer d'un coup de fusil son
cousin bernard laroche qui était
toujours inculpé pour le meurtre mais
qui semblait sur le point d'être
innocenté le meurtrier s'est aussitôt
rendu aux gendarmes
emilie raffoul un qui fait la manche
même si j'ai pas vraiment pourquoi haut
pour qu'il a fait ça et si c'était pas
bernard arrange
je peux le lire n'importe qui il sait
innocent j'espère que le vrai coupable
se retrouver un jour d'accusation en
dénégation de suspicion en inculpation
tout était déjà largement compliqué dans
cette affaire grégory le meurtre
aujourd'hui de bernard laroche par jean
marie villemin va-t-il paradoxalement
éclaircir les choses mais aujourd'hui la
tension a encore franchi un pas c'est
les proches de bernard laroche
il ya quelque chose qui se produit c'est
que la justice est tellement bien fait
que jean marie villemin veut faire
passer pour fou qui va faire trois ans
ou 80 de prison ou dans maison de dalian
et où j'arrive comme ça qui ressortira
comme avant le cir sans compas du sort
traîne dans le coin à la station sortir
tu ne seras pas qu'ils sortiront quand
jean marie villemin est arrivé pour ton
mariage marché ouvert la porte n'avait
pas peur je suis prêt on n'était pas là
a battu d'arriver si mario rejeté avec
gore cache des choses qu'on sait c'est
que maintenant en vagabond et puis là la
police n'a pas fait son boulot
ah ça fait trois semaines qu'il était
prévenu qu' il avait menacé la menace et
bernard devaud ma belle soeur avait
téléphoné aux gendarmes genre hier nous
aurions nous sortirait entier nous
regarde plus voilà face à la gendarmerie
française le juge lambert actuellement
en vacances doit se poser bien des
questions ce soir il se retrouve face à
un nouveau crime est toujours sans
réponse à celui de grégory il va falloir
rajouter deux couverts à la table de
l'europe
les ministres des affaires étrangères
des dix se sont mis finalement d'accord
pour accepter l'entrée dans le club de
l'espagne et du portugal
il reste tout de même à officialiser cet
élargissement les parlements de tous les
pays membres doivent l'entériner et
d'aborder ce soir les dix chefs d'état
et de gouvernement qui viennent
d'arriver à bruxelles montre en discuter
encore et s'efforceront d'aplanir les
dernières difficultés à bruxelles jean
marie beney ce sommet de bruxelles
marque pour la première fois depuis
longtemps un retour à la normale
rarement un conseil européen avait
débuté sur un terrain sis proprement
déblayer ou presque
l'accord au finish de la nuit dernière
sur l'élargissement n'attend plus qu'une
approbation au sommet en principe sans
problème sauf si la grèce estimant trop
défavorisés se fait un peu tirer
l'oreille
mais c'est le seul nuage sur ce sommet
où l'optimisme général la décontraction
aussi comme par exemple avec ce bain de
foule bon enfant d'helmut kohl au milieu
des manifestants pro européen ils
veulent plus d'europe
ce sommet débarrassé des scories terme à
la mode depuis athènes il ya quinze mois
va s'attaquer enfin aux vrais problèmes
qui sont de sa compétence
ce saut politique en avant aura deux
impératifs redonner vigueur aux
institutions européennes
cela veut dire plus d'efficacité vote à
la majorité qualifiée donc plus de
pouvoirs et fait rentrer davantage
l'europe dans la vie de tous les jours
des citoyens
mais au delà c'est aussi un renforcement
de la coopération sur les technologies
de pointe et surtout les
télécommunications et une relance des
grands travaux publics d'infrastructures
au plan européen
la reprise de la croissance doit d'abord
servir à la création d'emplois mais sans
égoïsme
le premier sujet abordé aujourd'hui
portait sur l'aide à l'afrique affamés
une page de l'europe est tournée a dit
michel vauzelle le porte parole de
l'elysée dans un an douze pays seront
ici à val duchesse sur la traditionnelle
photo de famille mais au delà du cliché
est bien plus important qu'on ne le
soupçonne encore est ce rééquilibrage
très forts de l'europe du nord vers le
sud et donc vers la méditerranée
bien sûr le passage de l'europe des dix
l'europe des 12 peut être considéré de
deux façons du point de vue politique
c'est l'arrivée d'un sang neuf et on
peut y voir une manière de renforcer
l'europe
l'aspect économique de cet élargissement
pose beaucoup plus de problèmes c'est
bien pourquoi du reste on a dû en
discuter aussi longtemps et lierre
encore jusqu'à une heure avancée de la
nuit pour parvenir enfin à cet accord
kherif qu'elle iso c'est fait l'europe
des 12 est devenu réalité tôt ce matin à
l'issue de longues négociations pêche
agriculture affaires sociales les
dossiers sont bouclés
reste toutefois une question qui devrait
être réglé avant demain soir par le
conseil européen
celle des programmes intégrés
méditerranéens cher à la grèce ces aides
financières destinée à parer le
contre-pied de l'élargissement pour la
pêche selon roland dumas et les
professionnels les intérêts de la france
sont garantis la flotte espagnole du
nord-est atlantique est limité à 300
avis
flotte qui ne sera renouvelée qu'à
moitié par exemple il faudra deux vieux
chalutier d'une puissance déterminée
pour un chalutier 9 au 1er janvier 80
645 bateaux espagnols auront le droit de
pêcher en même temps les poissons de
fond la france maintient sa protection
côtière atlantique de 12000 et fait
admettre la nécessité de moyens de
surveillance indispensable côté
agriculture période transitoire de 10
ans pour les fruits et légumes espagnols
rien ne change pour les quatre premières
années le souhaitait la france puis
démantèlement progressif des droits de
douane pour le vin les espagnols devrait
distiller au dessus de 23 millions trois
cent soixante quinze mille hectolitres
il en espérait 4 millions de puces enfin
les portugais pourront produire 120
mille tonnes de tomates en profitant
davantage à l'exportation bénéficié d'un
prêt de 7 milliards de francs sur 6 ans
pour soutenir leur balance des paiements
et compter sur un remboursement de tva
de 9 milliards de francs
pendant sept ans
françoise lasserre vous êtes chargé de
recherche la fondation nationale des
sciences politiques et vous êtes
spécialisé dans les affaires européennes
alors cet accord d de cette nuit c'est
une victoire de la communauté européenne
ou bien une victoire de ces deux pays
qui en quelques années ont accédé à la
démocratie
très franchement je crois que c'est une
victoire des deux de la colline au top
en europe est rien évidemment
puisqu'elle confirme sa vocation à
l'unification de l'ensemble du continent
européen et de ces pays candidats qu'ils
attendaient pour l'un depuis 1978 pour
l'autre leur part en 1979 que les 10
donnent leur feu vert à l'entrée dans la
communauté rappelle il se sentait
rejeter de ce club de démocratie nous
racheter d'une loi il avait l'impression
que les obstacles à la rentrée dans ce
club était important et il l'était en
effet mais effectivement eu ce laps de
temps entre l'ouverture des négociations
et la conclusion de l'accord a en effet
de temps en temps ceci fait leur
impatience
et alors nous allons il faut et dans
quelques instants
nous allons voir ce que va être cette
communauté européenne à 12 avec
marie-claire tiers la population totale
de la communauté sera de 320 millions de
personnes soit 7 % de la population
mondiale les richesses produites dans la
cee vont progresser de près de 10%
déjà premier exportateur mondial la cee
augmentera son chiffre d'affaires dans
les pays extérieurs de 5%
mais l'adhésion des pays ibériques se
traduira aussi par un appauvrissement
moyens avec une baisse du produit
intérieur brut par tête d'habitant
le taux d'inflation moyen de la
communauté va s'accroître
la hausse des prix était de 6 % en 1984
dans la communauté à 10 mais elle était
de plus de 11% en espagne et près de 31%
portugal de plus la communauté va
hériter de 3 millions de chômeurs qui
vont s'ajouter aux quelques 14 millions
actuellement recensés par ailleurs les
deux nouveaux pays vont devoir lutter
contre la compétitivité des produits de
la cee
effectivement la productivité de
l'espagne est inférieur de 40% à celle
de la communauté et l'écart est encore
plus sensible avec le portugal
enfin la superficie agricole de la
communauté va augmenter de près d'un
tiers ce qui se traduira par une
progression des exportations
subventionnées de produits agricoles
alors françoise de le faire cet
élargissement ne cache-t-il pas un
risque celui d'une europe large mais
moins forte parce que les intérêts des
pays vont se multiplier
parmi les difficultés que risque de
provoquer sa fille large issement il ya
bien entendu les risques de blocage
institutionnel car la communauté à 12
sera naturellement beaucoup plus
difficile à faire fonctionner que la
communauté a dit en outre il s'agira
d'une organisation coup plus lourd sur
le plan logistique si vous pensez par
exemple aux problèmes linguistiques
problème de traduction que la communauté
a dit et bien entendu l'entrée du
portugal et de l'espagne après celles de
la grèce dans la communauté rappelle
augmentera également la dimension
proprement sud de la communauté et donc
la dimension des problèmes nord-sud au
sein de cette communauté
cela implique bien évidemment ce test de
ce design fait de parler
jacques delors ces jours derniers il
faut que la communauté soit préparé à
faire notamment sur le plan financier
un effort important en faveur de ces
familles ici de la communauté ma
dernière question sera plus culturelle
française de la c est ce là une
ouverture vers le monde hispanique bien
sûr et il est tout plat toute la mairie
du sucre ou toute l'amérique latine
je pense qu'en effet c'est une des
choses qui a compté pour les dif
ils ont des gens à d'ailleurs amélioré
considérablement dans les années
écoulées leurs relations avec l'amérique
latine mais effectivement l'attrait de
l'espagne dans la communauté européenne
avec tout ce que lis annie date de paix
signifié à cet égard est certainement
sur le plan culturel très important mais
je crois aussi que à l'heure où l'on
parle beaucoup de la relance politique
de l'europe à l'heure où il semble qu à
nouveau des discussions sur une
éventuelle défenseur apn lieu le fait
élargissement à l'espagne au portugal a
aussi une dimension stratégique très
importante est bien évident qu'il
renforce dans le cas d'adhésion de
lesparre et à l'otan mais puisque le
portugal vit à paris
je crois que nous avons eu un petit
problème avec cet entretien qui a été
enregistré il y à une demi heure à peu
près en grèce élection mouvementée pour
la succession de constantin caramanlis
sous la présidence de la république ce
matin le parlement a finalement élu au
troisième tour le candidat de la gauche
christophe aretakis élue à une voix près
mais cette élection aussitôt a été
contestée par l'opposition qui l'a jugé
irrégulière mais mona a fait jean terme
à une élection historique pour la
première fois la grèce c'est d'un
président de lourches et pourtant on
retiendra surtout que c'est troisième
tour de scrutin était houleux le
parlement comme l'opinion en sorte
déchiré parce que l'élection est déjà
protesté christophe sarthe et actrice 56
ans a obtenu le minimum 180 voix dont
celle du président du parlement et
président de la république par intérim
c'est inconstitutionnel clame
l'opposition mais celle ci n'a pas remis
en cause la personnalité du christ au
start et à tous c'est lui le juge
intègre qui a refusé de céder aux
pressions
refuser la dictature des colonels dans
la sphère lembras crise en 1960 fois le
leader pacifiste grec assassiné par
l'extrême droite
un premier ministre messieurs papandréou
socialiste un président de la république
socialiste le pasok domine la vie
politique à athènes par takis accepter
sa charge
je le cite pour la liberté la justice la
démocratie en france une fusillade ce
soir dans un bar de bayonne un homme a
été tué et plusieurs personnes ont été
blessées il s'agit vraisemblablement
d'un acte terroriste car ce bar est
généralement fréquentée par des
nationalistes basques
il semble que l'auteur de la fusillade
ait pu être arrêtée suite du grand
feuilleton politique de la semaine sur
le mode de scrutin les parlementaires
socialistes qui sont divisés sur cette
question et qu'ils viennent d'en
discuter pendant deux jours à rennes ont
finalement décidé qu'il ne déciderait
pas ils vont laisser au gouvernement le
soin de choisir entre la proportionnelle
le scrutin majoritaire ou encore un
mélange des deux décisions un peu
surprenante à propos de laquelle michel
naudy interroge maintenant claude
escrime
oui cette décision surprend parce que le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que les
socialistes n'ont pas fait l'économie
d'un débat
vous avez discuté de ce problème
important au comité directeur aux
journées parlementaires au bureau
exécutif
vous ne décidez pas vous semblez laisse
elysées décider à votre place la
question est évidente
à quoi sert le parti socialiste dans
cette affaire c'est une question qu'on
se pose chaque fois qu'il ya un débat
long parti socialiste et ça arrive assez
souvent
dieu merci je voudrais d'abord dire que
aux journées parlementaires nous n'avons
pas consacrer deux jours à parler de la
réforme électorale nous avons parlé de
beaucoup d'autres choses et notamment de
tout ce qui va être fait dans le courant
de l'année 1985 le premier ministre
lui-même meyer a donné un certain nombre
d'orientations très intéressante qui
montre que l'action du gouvernement se
propose d'aller très au delà de
l'échéance de mars 1986 ce qui est déjà
une indication intéressante
bon en ce qui concerne la réforme
électorale il serait quand même étonnant
pour le parti n'en discute pas et que
les députés qui sont les premiers
concernés
non on discute pas nous en avons discuté
avec deux critères si vous voulez et
d'une part le souhait de réformer le
mode de scrutin dans un sens de plus
grande justice
d'où l'idée d'introduire de la
proportionnelle et ceci l'ailleurs est
conforme au programme du parti
socialiste depuis 1972 aux propositions
du candidat françois mitterrand 1981 et
puis nous avons nous en avons discuté
aussi dans le souci de déterminer un
mode de scrutin simple qui soit
compréhensible par les français et qui
ne donne pas le sentiment qu'on est en
train comme le prétend l'opposition de
tripatouiller de magouiller etc voilà
précisément à cet égard à ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment que la longueur
de ces discussions voire même les thèses
créé contradictoires qui sont exprimés
dans ces débats nourrissent précisément
ce soupçon qui pèse sur vous à l'apa à
la fois de la part de l'opposition mais
aussi à la fois du côté du parti
communiste mais chaque fois que le parti
socialiste débats ont dit les
socialistes sont divisés
divergences et c'est à dire et on si le
parti socialiste était un parti
monolithique comme le sont d'ailleurs
d'autres formations politiques
françaises williams on ne se pose pas ce
genre de problème parce qu'on ne discute
jamais bon dans le parti socialiste on
discute et j'avoue ceci est facile à
admettre que le problème du mode de
scrutin peut donner lieu à beaucoup
d'imagination je joue parce que aussi le
problème du manque de spectacle pose
aussi le problème des alliances
politiques et on peut se demander si le
choix la proportionnelle est fait par
exemple dans le cadre départemental
c'est l'hypothèse qui tient la corde
semble-t-il quoi qu'on en sache pas
beaucoup attendant la décision de
l'elysée la décision sera connue
prochainement donc on pourra à ce moment
là sur la base des textes qui sortiront
du conseil des ministres avoir une
discussion sur le contenu réel
oui mais on sait que l'on va vers la
potence ionel on va vers la
proportionnelle et la faveur de la
proportionnelle est la question que l'on
peut poser au delà de cette question de
technique qu'est la question du mode de
scrutin c'est de savoir c'est pas ça si
raisons techniques s'il était justement
si derrière il n'ya pas une autre
question politique et celle des
alliances
le problème n'est pas de savoir si le
parti socialiste change en deux le mode
de scrutin ne veut pas aussi changer ses
élèves traditionnel je voudrais répondre
à sa sphère de répondre d'abord la
proportionnelle c'était un engagement
commun du parti socialiste et du parti
communiste c'était donc lié à une
alliance qui était celle de l'union de
la gauche
je dirais qu à l inverse si on regarde
un peu l'histoire il faut quand même
regarder l'histoire puisque en france on
a généralement vu le scrutin majoritaire
à deux tours succéder à la
proportionnelle et la proportionnelle
succéder au scrutin majoritaire à deux
tours
et bien en 1936 le front populaire
alliance de gauche a été élu avec le
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
et la même assemblée la même chambre des
députés déjà à l'époque qui avait été
élu avec ces scrutins a abouti en 1940
aux pleins pouvoirs à pétain la même
donc c'est pas le mode de scrutin qui
avait déterminé l'alliance elle était
partie sur une alliance elle a terminé
sur une autre donc je crois que on ne
peut pas lier le problème de l' alliance
politique au problème du mode de scrutin
n'est pas ça la question
il avait 97 ans et ce petit homme au
regard malicieux avait gardé lé allures
d'un enfant prodige
marc chagall à des peintres les plus
célèbres du siècle est mort doucement la
nuit dernière dans sa maison de saint
paul de vence chagall s'était installé
en france juste après la guerre et même
s'il n'avait jamais perdu son accent
russe
il avait fait de la france sa patrie
hélène risacher il était l'enfant de
vittek petit village de russie que sa
peinture a rendu célèbres russe est juif
chagall est fasciné par la bible pour
lui elle est la plus grande source de
poésie de tous les temps le musée du
message biblique à nice réuni plus de
450 de ses oeuvres consacrées à la
religion arrivé à paris pour la première
fois en 1910 il découvre la lumière à
l'origine de sa passion pour les
couleurs
c'est une peinture de figuration les
figurations chagall né par l'abstraction
il détestait même l'abstraction il
disait 13 et pertinents il avait ses
vues très nette mer on peut dire d'abord
c'est une peinture classique pour le
sens que c'est de la figuration
les thèmes de la vie les thèmes de la
vie qu à ses lecteurs des rêves les
choses auxquelles les gens songent et il
touche les gens parce qu'il touche à la
rave quand vous pourrez parler de
l'amour c'est pas pour mon serment
l'amour plastiquement plastique
c'est un mode le caire si vous voulez
quelque chose sans quoi vous ne pouviez
pas même faire une pomme butin
en
je ne comprends pas chagall mais ne fait
pas de gestion je ne suis pas les
dollars des rares car le grand maître
marc chagall n'aimait pas beaucoup les
questions indiscrètes ta vie c'était le
travail seul dans son atelier ensuite
seulement l'oeuvre exposée comme ici le
fameux plafond de l'opéra de paris
des gens s'approchait de lui et très
impressionnés passer pour un personnage
alors en approchait en disant bonjour m
et les régates est il disait parce qu'il
avait après joli sens du pot il disait
on va mettre pas du tout senti même
chagall peintre mais aussi poète à ses
heures celui qui dit il y a beaucoup
gagné deux personnages dans mes tableaux
parce que sur terre il ya autant dan et
de jean la vague des départs s'amplifie
sur antenne 2 après celui d'albert du
roy le directeur de la rédaction
christine crainte vient d'annoncer à son
tour qu'elle renonçait à ses fonctions
de rédacteur en chef et de présentatrice
du journal de 20 heures elle explique
qu'elle n'a pas obtenu du pdg de la
chaîne jean claude et vers l'est les
garanties professionnelles qu'elle me
demandait
l'événement sportif de la semaine c'est
le dernier match du tournoi des cinq
nations france galles demain après midi
sur la pelouse du parc des princes à
paris certes la france a maintenant peu
de chances de remporter le tournoi
car le grand favori et l'irlande qui va
affronter en même temps l'angleterre
mais la rencontre de demain peut-être au
moins l'occasion pour les français de
finir en beauté
et parmi ces français on observera
particulièrement eric bonneval qui est
une révélation de cette année et qui
demain jouera son premier match de
tournoi
dominique champeau
jeune homme de son temps eric bonneval
et le type même du joueur physique un
débutant au solide et tranquille dont
les 81 kg ont déjà martyrisé l'été
dernier le verrou des familles
all-blacks trois quarts centre de métier
mais est lié par vocation ou par
nécessité il entrera vie et sans
complexe dans la mêlée dû tourner la
tournée certains grands débuts pour moi
j'étais en place à jeter entre un cours
de math
j'invite le plus marqué c'est ce que
c'était déjà très bien
là c'est autre chose tout à fait autre
chose si vous être le seul à porter le
fait de jouer à l'ale danger l'équipe
comme l'équipe de france qui est une
équipe une attaque prédomine c'est une
consécration volet lié pour un joueur
c'est sûr institue de fait si le
portugais n'est pas un poste du rejet
sur un poste on peut s'exprimer
donc c'est avec un plaisir toujours al
cc nous passions c'est tout sur le
plaisir de joueurs etc open de découvrir
deux d'avoir des contacts plus ou moins
violents c'est ça le plaisir c'est un
nouveau stade
voilà pour un stade ce paradis des
professions de foi pour un apôtre qui a
décidé de prêcher dans leur but gallois
il n'y a jamais que quelques foudres de
son paraître à la terre promise
autre couac quotidien maintenant sur les
marchés financiers avec henry lauret le
dollar continue la baisse qu'il a
amorcée au début de cette chaîne
regardons et bien voilà une semaine qui
s'achève comme la précédente sur une
baisse sensible du dollar
la confiance ce n'est plus aussi
inébranlable il s'en faut et la baisse
des taux d'intérêt les tiraillements
dans système bancaire américain et les
difficultés financières du brésil tout
cela n'arrange pas les affaires du
dollar qui a coté 942 à paris un proche
de pâques la bourse de paris a quelque
peu ralenti son parent qui était jusqu'à
hier un pas de charge les étrangers
continuent d'acheter les valeurs
françaises ont reflété un très léger
repli en fin de séance à new york enfin
la visite de ronald reagan à wall street
n'a pas bouleversé a marché où il est
vrai on n'a pas l'habitude de faire du
sentiment en milieu de séance légère
hausse mais très légère hausse du dow
jones le temps demain beaucoup de nuages
le matin de la bretagne aux flandres ils
donneront de la pluie sur les côtes de
la manche
ensuite ils s'étendront jusqu'à l'île de
france les pays de loire et la champagne
partout ailleurs il y aura du soleil et
les températures seront agréables
demain matin ses températures les
minimales serein presque normale pour la
saison c'est la conséquence du retour de
l'air doux venu par le sud-ouest nous en
avons sans doute fini cette année dit la
météo avec les gelées nocturnes les
pronostics de monsieur courtine
maintenant pour le tiercé qui demain se
dispute à saint cloud sur 22 partants il
a choisi le numéro 6 qui est son joker
las le 4 le dise le nice est le 18 et le
voilà demain soir nous avons rendez vous
à 21h 45 55 même exactement
bonne fin de soirée sur l'a3 ou les
programmes se poursuivent avec du rock
maintenant avant cela je vous rappelle
les principaux titres que nous devons
développer
bonsoir ya demain
jean marie villemin le père du petit
grégory a tué son cousin bernard laroche
europe les dix réunis à bruxelles seront
bientôt douze l'espagne et le portugal
entre dans le club france galles demain
au parc des princes dernier match du
tournoi des cinq nations
non